я звертаюсь зараз до кожного народного
депутата нас все одно ніхто не бачить
крім нас з вами Давайте ми як на кухні
зараз поговоримо А скажіть мені будь
ласка А до кого До коли буде це зневага
до народних депутатів України до всіх до
мене до вас до кожного в Незалежності
від фракції ми не просте питання Чому в
слоті телеканалу рада можна побачити що
завгодно крім Верховної Ради України Ну
чому Ну мені можна хтось це пояснити от
Голова Верховної Ради Я дуже би хотів
почути відповідь іде слов рада на
Марафоні національному чому там нема
ради чому не можна записати наше
зібрання шановне і через декілька годин
Як ви розійдемося безпека дозволить
пустити показати людям що ми живі що ми
ходимо на роботу що будуть щось робимо з
вами бо люди тільки сміються чому над
нами Можна знущатися і забрати паспорти
дипломатичні з 25 кожного з нас з вами
чому коли є стаття Закону Про статус
народного депутата яка чітко каже що
дипломатичний паспорт дається кожному
народному депутату на час його
обов'язків і не можна забрати взяти чому
до нас так відноситься Міністерство
закордонних справ Як це можна дозволяти
об себе витирати ноги чому в нас коли
останній раз був уряд де уряд ми з вами
ходимо на роботу ми їх завжди тут з
першого дня 24 лютого ми зібралися
голосували за воєнний стан ми тут були в
березні коли російські війська були під
Києвом де наш Уряд Я забув як вони
виглядають чому ми не можемо їм задати
навіть питання Я розумію що для піару
скоро треба буде кожному з нас з вами Що
дрючком дати по спині на вході і люди
будуть аплодувати але ж Вибачте це ж
тоді на парламент А що це Годі вже друзі
давайте поважати себе